taylor c'est pas très beau parce que
l'hommage vaut mille mots
voilà une partie de sa jambe et parce
que la réalité frappe au coeur c'est sur
des faits réels que porte ce procès
interactif c'est donc une victime de
chair et de sang qui témoigne à la barre
j'ai vu le restant de ma jambe qui
étaient pendus sur le pare choc la
voiture juges procureurs avocats le jeu
de rôle est fidèle mais pour ses
assesseurs d'un jour et leurs camarades
il s'agit pas seulement d'évaluer la
peine du prévenu mais aussi de mesurer
les douleurs invisible celle d'une vie
professionnelle affective intime social
bouleversé choqué on se dit on va le
faire ça va aller mais quand ça tourne
mal on se dit pas ce que ça va faire aux
autres personnes en fait on évite de
faire ce niveau des troisièmes parce que
c'est quand même un petit peu il ya
certaines images peuvent être choquantes
mais on ne s'appartient de seconde
première terminale après bts bac +1 plus
de là c'est intéressant parce qu'on a
vraiment des réactions de jeunes
conducteurs et qu'ils prennent
conscience justement de ce que
représente la voiture qu'il faut
toujours le dire une arme par
destination
une arme qui tuent sans distinction
julien 19 ans la vie devant lui est mort
un samedi soir parce que le conducteur
qui le transportait avait bu et fumé ma
voiture pas pic de l'avant fait des
tonneaux par l'avant et puis elle
s'enfonce tout doucement dans la somme
25 mètres plus loin et je le père
raconte la lente agonie du fils sauver
des vies c'est devenu sa thérapie
j'avais besoin de d'extérioriser alors
que je sais qu'aujourd'hui à des
personnes qui est qui qui met une
une chape de plomb de silence de sur un
événement comme ça vous pensez que ce
genre de journée de sensibilisation
c'est vraiment ils devraient l'art
puisse beaucoup plus des témoignages que
les jeunes soient beaucoup plus touchés
l'ombre de choc sera t-elle plus
efficace qu'un spot télé le verdict
tombera plus tard mais ne soyez pas
inconscient